everyone this is T one job with glider
and I'm here with the team behind Peter
brother Falcon um how are you guys doing
today really good I feel awesome thank
you um how are you I'm doing excellent
we're covering movies this is fantastic
before we get any further I just wanted
we're at South by the only reason we get
to be at South by is because we have
sponsors want to give a huge thank you
to Blue Moon - hint it to everybody
who's gotten us here at the studio suite
because without these sponsors we
wouldn't be able to cover movies like
yours so I just want to give a huge
thank you jumping in I have not seen the
film yet but I saw on Twitter last night
the tremendous reaction to the film
socially and I just want to know what
was it like being in that world premiere
last night because it sounds like it
went over great yeah it felt great Zach
what it feel like to you in there I
would say he was very yeah for me it
felt pretty rad it was um we got like a
standing ovation and people were nobody
left for the QA people are seem very
engaged and very into Zac's performance
and shyest performance and it was a it
was a blessing probably a real blessing
to get to experience that here at South
by a lot of people in fact I would wager
almost everyone watching this interview
will not have seen the film yet and I
hate asking the generic question but do
you mind talking a little bit about what
the film is about no we do not come here
to do that we'd love to yeah you wanna
yeah I mean I'll just do it one line you
guys can tag in it's um it's a film
about a young man with Down syndrome
that breaks out of retirement home to
chase his dream of becoming a
professional wrestler
that's our log line yeah yeah it's exact
it's Zach it's Shia LaBeouf it's Dakota
Johnson and we wrote this film for Zach
I've known that for a lot of years eight
years now yeah yeah and we're all really
really tight friends and Zack really had
a dream of being a professional actor
and being in movies and we knew that
that probably wasn't gonna happen for
Zack because he's not he's on opera just
not something that people with Down
syndrome get an opportunity to do a lot
and we were like let's just write him a
movie because we love we love you and we
thought thought he was a really talented
actor we'd see him do stuff and like
smaller things and you know smaller
projects and he was actually like really
turned on in front of a camera and
though he's a little tired right now
big night last night right yeah yeah but
but yeah he's a he's a really really
talented actor and so we really came
crafted it for him it's nice to see that
I'll come together last night the thing
about it though is that you guys put
together this hella cast and that sounds
terrible English but a hell of a cast
yeah
say hello cast yeah but I mean like I
mean Shia is a great actor and you know
he's selective with what he chooses to
do Dakota great assic yeah like mazing
you got actors that are like look it's
like a murderer's row of talent how the
f did you have like compromising photos
what how would you do this i all the
time and i actually don't know how i
think it's the stars align we're very
very lucky you like the script yeah and
wanted to be a part of it we we the
three of us bless you over there I've
said enough was in sound you're welcome
I got you yeah just blessings we had the
three of us in our friend Dave had gone
and made a proof of concept which is
essentially like a trailer to sort of
show the the script off because we
couldn't convince anyone to read it and
then making sort of like a very small
trailer proof of concept short film for
it was like five minutes right with all
of us got people intrigued and reading
the script I think that's really how we
convinced people to do it I think it was
the proof of concept and I also think
that was like Shia signed on and I think
Shia is a real actors
magnet and other great producers it
started started to build it was like a
brick wall you know you get try to do
something to get Dakota you get some of
our great producers and people they've
worked with in the past they Albert and
Ron had worked with John Hawkes and
Bruce turned before so they were able to
you know make really personal calls yeah
they didn't abrasca and with with Bruce
and yeah we're really lucky and blessed
and like honestly like you a part of me
was like can you tell us what happened
because it is a real great it's so crazy
I don't understand it myself because I
looked at the cast list and I was just
like wait what meet you I'm still that
way yeah you know but what is it like on
set directing like someone like Bruce
Dern or Tom's Aidan Church like some
really you know John Hawkes yeah like
the list goes on and on sort of like
this who's going hey you guys are great
during the [ __ ] you want everybody I
think showed up and saw that we were
doing a movie they were taking really
seriously and brought their best
performances and also Zach I think
really contributed to an environment
where people fell in love with each
other and were really connected so I
mean John and Thomas Haden Church and
Brewster and I think felt like a really
special environment they took Tyler and
I aside and said sets aren't normally
like this you guys this is really
special so we got some feedback to them
yeah we were doing like group hugs and
stuff and people don't always group hug
and I was like what we do love we love
hugs
what when I was reading the synopsis and
what takes place in the film it sounds a
little bit like Huck Finn esque or am I
wrong about this no we certainly we love
Mark Twain might speak to them yeah we
love Mark Twain we love stories that
feel like a different time in place and
sort of that the feeling of being in
literature and then Tyler grew up in the
Outer Banks of North Carolina so a lot
of these locations we wrote specifically
for yeah we thought we're gonna shoot it
for 200 bucks and like we'd never
thought we'd have a budget let alone a
cast like that so I knew that I could go
to my hometown in North Carolina and
shoot the marshes and no one was gonna
charge me or you know check for permits
and stuff so that's why we wrote it like
that but we ended up shooting in Georgia
and we used
yeah I heard rumors that's important
yeah you know who knows yeah the kid
didn't literally no way to tell right I
am a huge fan of Shia and one of the
things about Shia that I really respect
is he goes full force
yes into his performances he gives
everything yes all the time yes I have
so much respect what is it like working
with someone like that who is so
committed to his performance have you
ever seen a lion tear apart an innocent
animal it's like he is a ferocious force
of pretend like he's so he's wonderful
of that analogy inspiring
I'd say for me it's really yeah and I
can see the ripple effect that it had on
every other position in on set other
actors other crew people I think we're
really inspired to level up and meet him
where he was doing it you did seem too
shy after the on suffer on mashing when
Shia I will say Shyam knows about what
he was doing and Shia knows how to you
know corny about some stuff about what
he wants to do so that's for because I'm
sorry so I always listen to Tyler and
Mike always and the whole time and so I
know about all the bunch of the stuff we
we always do together yeah yeah I'm
sorry and me I've been doing all the fun
stuff and full around and having a very
good time and then you know so I always
be the best one I'd never have to just
to our work with hotel me yeah we'd all
kind of block it out together and talked
about how we wanted to shoot it and how
Nigel wanted to shoot at our DP and
create a dance floor for these guys and
yeah we I guess that was her house
direct I don't know now if that got away
from your question no it's fine I'm
always curious about the editing process
everyone in this room has heard me say
this again and again yes ultimately the
final rewrite yes so oh yeah how did the
film change in the editing room and what
did you learn from any screenings the I
mean our editing team I'll say keV
intent and that fuller are amazing at
hers Kevin attest um he's got a lot of
range got like blow he cut Girl
Interrupted he cut a bunch of Alexander
Payne's up so higher and I were learning
a lot about Co yeah and you said put it
perfectly the final rewrite we were
learning a lot about writing while he
was editing you know what do you leave
it on the last line of a scene and then
why still when I'm writing I still call
him I can you read this scene like I
legit like I love him he yeah he's a
fantastic editor and then I think our
tastes higher and ours taste was for the
authentic moments or the things that
came up that weren't necessarily
scripted so we chased those down and
with Kevin and Nats knowledge of how
things are supposed to go and with our
pushing of like hey it doesn't matter if
that's out of focus we're using it yeah
figure out how to get it in there please
I think we landed a really unique and
genuine place and we also Mike comes
from an edit background and I had a
pretty good understanding about it so
it's when we're shooting we have a
pretty decent idea of how how it can
kind of cobble together did you do you
I'm imagining making this with this
level of the you know the crew and the
talent behind it that you must have
learned a few things that you're gonna
take with you oh yeah for future things
yeah what's like a lesson or two that
you're like oh my god I wish I'd known
this earlier or things that you know
you've thought about yeah I think VFX
being able paint things out yes you have
a budget that's amazing one yeah you
just get rid of that the change the
truck can not be there you know that was
a huge one understand that was a real
possibility with not a huge budget you
know mm-hmm what about you what did you
what you learn in this film I I don't
have been learned
as so many things I want Tyler Tyler
Tyler just tell me how to get I'm
staying focused and this ditch don't
lose all all of the words and for me
about I still I still always do it right
I matter what what I do and I'll except
for except for Mike Mike have been you
know I'm telling me like I would say
it's good to sit by the beach and I'm
just - I'm blitzing and never say any
word until before until before I'm Mike
say get up and go action but the effects
is it was it was really long days I'll
say I learned that I learned how much is
possible within a 12-hour day oh I got
something I learned yeah can I go - is
it alright I learned to not eat like an
[ __ ]
because sometimes with crafts you can
get in the way and you're just you just
I start eating Reese's Cups and Oreos
and then obviously the next day I felt
terrible so I'm next next when I shoot
I'm gonna really set an intention keep
me accountable to eat a little bit
cleaner you know a lot of people talk
about yeah they don't realize it's a
marathon it is and three marathons yeah
our little directors a total different
yes writer yes sorry but they a lot of
people talk about how it's a marathon
and who need to pace yourself yes I got
a funny side note I was talking to James
Wan for Aquaman yeah I talked about how
he was eating what Jason was eating to
try to keep him or look eating super
healthy huh to keep him going because of
the crazy hours yeah we're doing that
South by Southwest I'm trying to eat
like clean cuz I'll get you know I'll
get tired I also eat my emotions I don't
know if you do that but I'll get I get
very emotional and I'll eat and it's not
hard to resist donut it's so hard and
there's that voodoo doughnut I've had
those yet I want to try and no I have
any I'm gonna let you know right now
they're what we call good and they're
like people literally fire sugar out of
your fingers after you're done
and it's completely worth it okay it's
just fantastic well I've been still in
the mirror I'm on the South by Southwest
marathon so maybe I'll hit that one up
on the last mile or something what is
what's the story with four people that
want to see the movie or is it for sale
here what what's yeah what's the story
yeah yeah we're looking for distribution
and there's I guess agents and producers
working on that mostly we're not real
intimately involved in that but yes I
did that people are more creative sure I
would say though that you have a very
strong leg up with the cast that you've
put together thank you I mean it really
I mean the truth is it really matters
like you know because it's easier to get
in front of eyeballs when you have
people like this it is totally true yeah
no I agree I mean you know no BS it's
obvious you know yeah it's I fully
accept that as a thing in our industry
famous people sell movie tickets it's
absolutely true yeah um I obviously want
to ask what are you guys writing now
what's with you know what I mean we got
a TV show going that we've we've written
to be really honest our energy is really
centralized on seeing this one through
so I don't even feel like as a writer
safe to be like all right I got this
other pitch for you so it's really just
trying to be here and be present with
Zack and our crew and our guys and
that's where my energy is you know I've
learned from a lot of other filmmakers
that have you know when they're selling
a project like after this you know
because if it has any sort of buzz you
get back home and then people want to do
a meeting and then they say well what do
you want to do next yeah better have
that answer
I learned this thank you I do have that
answer and I'm grateful I I will I'm
just trying to no no I just want an
answer I think in this I think it's
important I agree with you I think it's
really important to have that answer I
also don't I don't think we've ever
played by those rules in a way like I
think we're just sort of like doing our
best to I do my best to be here with you
guys you know first is uh trying to have
an answer for my next thing I think it's
really Hollywood to do that but I don't
even have it we don't have agents or
anything we're not those we're not real
Hollywood dudes so you know maybe I'll
build a house next I could see I would
love to build a house
yeah like with my own hands and stuff
that would be cool I'm giving you guys
huge props for putting this thing
together thank you I really mean it it's
a hell of an accomplishment thanks man
and I really sincerely can't wait to see
it thank you yeah it really truly made
year if you're like a Shia LaBeouf fan
his performance is this and this is yes
amazing
I believe me I just saw honey boy at
Sundance he's phenomenal in that like
he's a very very very talented actor I
love you know yeah I really love him
he's a wonderful human yeah I'm I'm
great thank you with me yeah he's our
team man he's our guy absolutely thank
you so much for coming yeah you know I'm
really grateful thank you thank you on
that note pleasure to meet you and let's
hit stop
you